which three I just replayed all the way
through love that game really became
Gucci fancy playing garel because
Netflix are making a which TV show
absolutely yeah that would be an amazing
read the books now I have in the Polish
box the books are amazing the books are
really really good yeah I think they're
gonna be adapting those for the TV show
yeah it's a what I understand school bit
of both
they're picking a bit from the game and
a bit from the book a lot from the books
but the books I started reading and they
are well worth the read they're really
really good hey everybody its charlie
if you didn't see the news this morning
or you couldn't tell from the clip that
I put at the beginning of this Henry
Cavill has officially been cast as
Geralt of Rivia for The Witcher Netflix
TV series so we got a freaked out about
this I know there are a lot of questions
about what's going on with the
characters in the story for the TV show
and what this means about him being
Superman in the DC Universe so I'll
dress The Witcher stuff first then I'll
talk about the Superman stuff if you're
a big Witcher fan you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I will talk about release
date because they start filming the
series in November through bring eight
episodes so they'll probably be filming
for most of the spring meaning that they
could possibly get it out by the end of
next year now because they're filming in
November it's gonna be winter in Europe
where they're filming so maybe in
keeping with that tone they also want to
release it during winter next year like
why would you shoot a winter based show
then release it in the middle of the
summer it would just seem kind of weird
most of you will probably remember this
is not Henry cavils first fantasy series
he was the Duke of Suffolk on tutors for
an entire series run sandy could bill
the nura large enough it is set upon the
cliffs of Dover his Majesty would be
able to see reflected in it
the movements of France ships in and out
of the port of the one
you see what I mean yogurt do you think
he's mad
so imagine white hair Duke of Suffolk
riding around kicking people's asses but
if there was any confusion about what
kind of story they're gonna be doing
this is based on the books not on the
videogame the story of the games
actually pick up after the novels leave
off so the games are sort of like a
spiritual sequel to the books the
original author of the main series had
nothing to do with the story of the
video games though so that was all the
studio just spinning out based on his
work they haven't confirmed all the
characters but the showrunner has talked
about some specific ones that I'll talk
about in a second but just in terms of
where the story picks up par for the
course for big fantasy series like this
like Game of Thrones or the Lord of the
Rings series is that you start with a
really big battle or some crazy action
scene then you either flash back or
start to explain who the characters are
so like Game of Thrones pilot opens with
the White Walkers then you go to all the
heroes so just imagine them opening this
series with him saving someone from a
monster or taking one down then for all
the people that have no experience with
the characters before they sort of
explain who he is what he does roving
silver-haired monster hunter for hire
with crazy powers like I said there's
only going to be eight episodes so it's
probably going to be a relatively
self-contained story I'm guessing that
they want to get at least five to seven
seasons out of this but because Henry
Cavill is such a big actor what they
might have done in order to lock him
down for multiple seasons like more than
you would normally expect is to just
give him more money it's just the idea
that this is going to be Netflix's
version of Game of Thrones they want it
to go big they're spending big dollars
so they want to keep their actor locked
down like they don't wanna have a
situation in season two where he's not
under contract and it takes him forever
to figure it out what I'm expecting is
is that they'll just adapt the book
story and they'll just slowly move
through season to season depending on
how many episodes they do if they only
do eight episodes for season one and
it's crazy popular maybe they'll do ten
episodes for season two but I wouldn't
expect them to go past ten episodes of
season because Henry Cavill still wants
to be a movie star and if you're
shooting like 13 15 16 episodes of
season or more than that
you don't have time to film a big movie
and he definitely wants to
be Superman in future DC movies so a lot
of people started freaking out when
they're like hey why is Henry Cavill
suddenly doing a TV series even though
The Witcher is a huge TV series and it's
really awesome people thought that it
might mean that he's not going to be
Superman anymore I think honestly what
happened is is DC told him that they
weren't quite ready and didn't have the
story or the right story to make Man of
Steel - so they told him that yeah we'll
totally renegotiate your contract for
Superman and you'll continue to appear
in cameos in future films while we
figure out the next Man of Steel film
but because you have all this extra time
on your hands to go do other movies just
go do whatever you want so they're not
postponing Man of Steel - because he's
doing The Witcher he's doing The Witcher
because they postponed Man of Steel to
is you know chicken or the egg which
came first they'll still make it there
were rumors that he did actually
renegotiate his contract for like six
more appearances like one of those would
be a cameo in the Shazam movie maybe a
cameo during the flash flashpoint movie
in any other future DC movies that would
fit the tone of his character but the
next big question you all have is is
who's going to play yennefer if henry
cavill is gonna be Geralt who will be
his yennefer they have not announced who
but she did say that she actually sat
down with henry cavill for the first
time four months ago so obviously he was
their most important hire so I'm
guessing that within about a month of
that they'd already started interviewing
people for the interfer role so they
probably already know who it is and
they're just waiting to sign the
contract the reason why they announced
this henry cavill news today is is
because they probably just got him to
sign his contract last week it probably
took that long to figure out how much
they were gonna pay him what the
schedule was gonna be so what'll
probably happen is is they continue to
lock the other actors down they'll
announce the other characters like Amir
built forts obviously he's the ultimate
big bat of the series don't know if
he'll be the big villain of the first
season or if they'll go a little bit
smaller and then work up to him but the
showrunner talked about 10 other core
characters including Amir village force
Jennifer in Siri they kind of confirmed
the timeline in their description of the
way that they view Siri / the books so
they described her as relentless growing
child with more power than she perhaps
realizes the writers explained Hearst
as being one about facing fears and
finding a family of her own that will
stand beside her through the harsh
moments of her journey so very young
version of Siri but we don't know
exactly how old once we know how old she
is you could place Geralt in the
timeline because there's a very specific
timeline in the books where she
encounters him for the first time the
way they describe yennefer is proud and
contradictory and how her story is all
about seeking to fill a hole in her
heart that she desperately wishes wasn't
there though sometimes she feels
vulnerable she is loath to show it the
way they described Tris makes it sound
like they might try to do the love
triangle from the video games but that
wasn't something from the books the
video games try to recreate that by
giving Geralt some amnesia so no idea if
they're gonna try and tackle that or how
they'll try to handle it but hopefully
that gives you an idea for some of the
casts that they've been talking about I
don't know if anything's gonna change
between now and when they actually start
filming but I'm assuming that these 10
core people will be a core part of the
series at some point maybe not everybody
quite as big during season 1 but I'm
sure by the time we get to season 2
season 3 they'll all be a pretty big
cast Game of Thrones style even though
Game of Thrones seems like it's always
had a really large cast of characters
they didn't start out that big in season
1 they kept expanding until they got to
about season 6 and started killing
people off and cutting storylines then
they started to whittle it down a little
bit so I'm assuming it's gonna be the
same type of treatment with The Witcher
series but like I said not expecting
this to drop before next winter just
because around the time Game of Thrones
Season 8 premieres they'll probably be
finishing filming their series so it'll
take them probably all summer and all
fall to get through post-production so
really good news we'll have Game of
Thrones Season 8 early next year around
the end of April hopefully they'll
finish Witcher by the end of that year
we'll freak out about that and then the
year after that they'll probably be
close to completing the Lord of the
Rings TV series that Amazon is doing so
a lot of really awesome fantasy TV is
coming up in the next couple of years
and just remember that even though Game
of Thrones main series is ending next
year their prequel series will start the
year after that so each year thereafter
we'll have Game of Thrones which are in
Lord of the Rings all in the same year
for hopefully five to seven years so I
am really really excited
do more casting videos for Witcher as we
learn about more of the characters but
leave all your requests in the comments
below click here for my review of the
Spider Man ps4 games that just dropped
and click here for brand new Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]